now can someone tell me who's this guy
this is Sir Isaac Newton and he's
generally regarded as an and I use that
word very deliberately and inventor of
calculus this topic this concept this
big idea this branch of mathematics
we'll be looking at however you need to
know that alongside Isaac Newton
there's this guy who is four years
younger who you need to know about not
just because he has such epic hair but
because number one he's a co-inventor of
calculus it took us a long time actually
a big argument AB it's bad about it
Newton was really unhappy he was like
you stole this from me
but more importantly for the purposes of
this lesson today Leibniz notation I'm
actually gonna write his name for you
because so important you should have it
yeah I know right
that was so 30 seconds ago right with me
right his name was Gottfried Wilhelm
Leibniz they just had such epic names
back in the day lied nets came up with a
different way of writing derivatives
just a different notation but it ended
up being the one which is far more
powerful and useful for us today and
it's the one I'm going to introduce to
you this morning so you can make a
little heading for me which is Leibniz
is derivative notation say it again sir
I got freed oh yes all the great
mathematicians at that time were okay so
let's put go fern and his um because
you're worth it here away and let's
think back to the derivative notation
that we have currently so far explored
right we've got this idea this is just
revision right of the difference
question the difference question and
it's this long fraction right we were
just thinking about gradient I'll give
you a reminder the bottom is H that's
the easy part
what's the numerator
very good f of X plus h and then yeah we
take the difference that it's the
difference question after all and then
we divide so this is we got this from
gradient right rise over run and then we
said well this is just an approximation
this is like measuring Usain Bolt over
nine point six nine seconds or one
second or half a second it's pretty
close but what if we could do it
precisely not over a sort of a chunk of
time but over an infinitesimally small
chunk of time so what we did was we
applied this thing called a limit do you
remember that right so we said if you
have an initial f of X then we can have
this gradient function the derivative
not an approximation at exact thing if
we take this guy and we apply a limit at
the front right so it took the same
difference question like so and we said
this is just not approximately close to
through the gradient this is exactly the
gradient at any particular value of x so
we've got our f of X notation our F Dash
and this is what we call differentiating
right okay so we have this notation we
want to introduce to you a different way
of talking about the same thing and I'm
going to show you why this ends up being
so useful so he comes live and it's his
alternative we often we often talk about
functions not as f of X or G of X or H
of X or all those kinds of things but we
often have a wrong color we often have a
function and we just call it Y right
y equals any of those things right we've
seen this before I could have asked you
please graph y equals this or y equals
this y equals this etc Y is our vertical
axis X our horizontal axis so seen this
before right if we've got Y as our
function of X right we can introduce
this new way of talking about the same
derivative we can say the derivative I'm
going to write it in this weird way I'm
gonna explain it right and some of you
might have seen this notation before
this is live knitters innovation right
he said I want to instead that this -
notation all that I'm going to call the
derivative dy on da
now what does this mean let me explain
think back think back the D actually
doesn't save the derivative that's just
a convenient coincidence
it also tell you what the D stands for
let's think about when you've got back
in arm back in like chemistry lands
right you know how you might get I don't
know I'm gonna I'm going to badly show
my lack of knowledge of chemistry right
now you know how we wrote chemical sort
of what do they call reactions right
reactions things happen right and then
you get some other products at the end
is ever remember what's the symbol we
write up here we write a little symbol
here it's actually a Greek letter we
write a delta it's a triangle but it's
it's the Greek letter Delta what does it
indicate in and gets change right now in
math we've sort of taken over this for
discriminants right but here in calculus
this ends up being useful because
calculus is all about how are things
changing what's the difference right
so this letter D here it's a very very
shorthand way of saying D for Delta it's
a change in Y compared to a change in X
in fact that's exactly what I would say
the easiest way to understand what is
DUI or DX mean it means change in Y
divided by change in X now that is a bit
of a mouthful and that's why we usually
say rise over run but that's all it is
how does y change how does X Change why
don't we just change it to a triangle
like just write this is that what you're
asking okay now the short answer is
remember coming back to this guy over
here right we have to go from this guy
which is the graining of the secant to
this guy which is the radian of the
tangent we do it by means of this we'd
limit business right so in fact there's
a lot happening underneath you it's not
just a fraction even though for all
intents and purposes that we're going to
be interested in I will treat it and I
can treat it as a fraction but in fact
this Delta Y Delta X it actually appears
earlier on in the technical definition
for where this comes from so that's why
we don't use the deltas there they
actually means something else which I'm
not going to I'm not going to pull back
the veil in that right now because
Franklin
don't need to okay but if you want
you're welcome to I'll give you the full
detailed thing later you'll end up at
the end thinking do I really need to
know all of that no you don't for the
purposes of what we got now but that's
why we don't use the Delta okay all
right so this is the idea DUI on DX when
you see that what that indicates is your
function Y your original function
differentiate that thing okay now I want
to talk us through I've got I've got a
list written here right I've got one two
three I've got three big advantages to
lightnin TSA's notation okay and each
one is actually important for a concept
that we're going to learn and we're
going to a skill we're going to use okay
so firstly excuse me
advantage number one I'll call it a 1
right it reminds us that when you go F -
right when you apply this process of
bringing that power at the front
reducing the power by 1 what you're
doing is you're working with a fraction
right this F - notation it kind of
disguises the fact that what you're
doing is is this this is what you're
doing but we've automated this process
because we proved it yesterday we're
like I don't need to go through first
principles for this which is a big
relief because for first principles I
would have to work out what on earth
that is and I I don't even know what
that is like that that power is too high
for me and it would take me forever
right we'll just be disgusting algebra
so we've automated this process we don't
have to go through first principles
anymore but we want you to remember
that's actually what's going on
underneath whenever you do an X to the 7
whenever you differentiate anything in
the future this is what's really going
on rise over run rise over run change my
change in X that's advantage number one
advantage number two it gives us a way
you're gonna make sure I get all my
details here right it gives us a way to
indicate what our derivative is about
now let me explain what I mean
when you see D Y on D X it indicates
this is a derivative comparing Y to X
think back to when we were having a look
at Usain Bolt right
when we first drew in fact go back to
that page when we drew remember we drew
a Cartesian plane and we we tried our
best to draw a sort of curve the
illustrated how he read remember that
you just go find that spot you should
have like two or three graphs on top of
each other which have you say boat on
them right on that set of axes we drew
it like this roughly but when we're
talking about you say involved we did
not have an x-axis or y-axis what did we
have we were comparing distance and time
right so we had actually not an x-axis
we had a t axis and on this distance
here well because of my use of the
letter D over here I'm not going to say
D for distance far more common and the
physics people know I would call this
actually displacement and I would call
it s right because these already taken
now if I want to say the derivative of
that I would not write dy on DX I am
comparing this displacement s with this
time T so instead of writing dy on DX I
would write for example D s on D tape
now we're going to start to encounter
places where you've got different things
being differentiated and you're paying
attention to different premiere rules
this becomes really really important
whereas this notation is just saying hey
just just differentiate what are you
looking at or just you work it out okay
this is being a little more explicit
about that's very very important so out
of this by the way out of this
particular advantage it gives us
something called the differential
operator so I want us to write this down
write the differential operator an
operator is something which you put in
front of something else in it it
performs something like for example sine
is an operator you'd say sine of 30
degrees do something to 30 degrees think
back to last thing when we're very very
briefly got introduced to logs logs are
an operator you'd say log of this number
so you take number and you pop it in
right
the differential operator is this thing
at the front of why right so what I
would say is D on DX whatever is going
to come next I want you to differentiate
it and have a look at the X's these are
the things I want you to bring the power
at the front
reduce by one etc right so the way you
might write this is D or DX of Y that is
dy on DX you can see how that Y just
kind of jumps up the front up the top
there okay so this is really important
to see what this means is we can say
when you read this you say oh the next
thing that comes for example you know
don't write this down but whatever is
over here like X to the 7 plus 3x plus 2
right whatever comes after that what
this is telling you to do is
differentiate that right it's an
operator has to operate on something
please do not write D on DX equals a
thing right because there's no thing
that's being operated on right and there
needs to be something in there like Y or
a function of some kind any of these
things okay I'm telling you this
specifically because when I got
introduced to the differential operator
when I was your age I did not understand
what it was so I wrote this because I
was like I don't know
it's just the derivative thing so just
off you go it's not a derivative it's an
operator that gives you a derivative
okay all right so I promise three
advantages first one was it reminds you
it's a fraction second one was it tells
you what you're dealing with what actual
objects you're differentiating lastly
I've run out of space down the bottom
which is a bit unfortunate but lastly
and this is something we're going to get
into in the second half of this lesson
it allows derivatives to interact with
each other derivatives can interact with
each other now that's a bit vague right
now because it's leaning into the next
concept what we're going to learn but I
want you to know like why are we going
to the F of introducing new notation the
old notation is fine like we really can
use it but
the new notation is better for doing all
of these things